[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
analizaremos la compleja y delicada
situación que vive nyan mar tras el
golpe de estado-militar del primero de
febrero partes de rangún la capital del
país han sido sometidas a la ley marcial
y ya son más de 180 los manifestantes
que han muerto por cuenta de la
represión policial en las
manifestaciones ciudadanas ante esto
continúa el pronunciamiento de la
comunidad internacional nos acompaña el
vibrio periodista y antropólogo autora
del libro birmania los caminos de la
libertad civil gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 a pesar de
toda la brutal represión por parte de
las autoridades los manifestantes
continúan en las calles en rechazo a
este golpe militar que podemos esperar
qué ocurre en mianmar y si existe la
posibilidad que los militares escuchen
al pueblo en sus reclamos
bueno la gente pide ayuda desde desde el
principio no desde el golpe de estado
estaban están pidiendo ayuda y a pesar
de los disparos avales área es que han
matado como lo decías más de 180
personas y a pesar de este miedo la
gente sigue manifestando esperando a una
intervención de las naciones unidas y
esperando que los que siguen haciendo
negocios con la junta militar para no y
estoy me estoy refiriendo a grandes
empresas internacionales que siguen
trabajando con la junta militar ahora ni
ahora son diversos los actores
internacionales que piden el cese de la
violencia en las calles de mianmar como
lo hizo por ejemplo el papá francisco
unas últimas horas sin embargo me han
mar pasó justamente su fin de semana más
sangriento continuará al alza esta
tendencia represiva por parte de las
autoridades
bueno podemos tenerlos porque en los
años no es la primera vez que
se levanta la gente para rechazar un
golpe militar o para protestar en contra
de esta junta en 1988 en el 2007
hubieron levantamientos la diferencia
con este rechazo de la población de la
junta militar es que el pueblo por
primera vez está realmente amigo hay que
saber que mi hermana es un país muy
fragmentado no hay 135 grupos étnicos y
hay algunas etnias grupos algunos grupos
étnicos que tienen grupos armados
también que están en tierra con el
ejército gubernamental desde casi el
principio desde la independencia del
país en 1948 así que podemos tener una
de las situaciones que vuelven más
violenta no y no sé cómo se va a volver
más violenta porque ahora estamos en una
situación de emergencia
y tareas de emergencia humanitaria si
bien ese orden de ideas la asociación de
monjes budistas más poderosas de mianmar
pidió a la junta que ponga fin a la
violencia contra los manifestantes y
acusó a una minoría armada de torturar y
matar a civiles inocentes desde el golpe
de estado del mes pasado que tanto peso
pueden tener estos monjes sobre las
decisiones que pueden tomar los
militares en el poder
es difícil saberlo bueno lo que hay que
entender es que el llamar en birmania la
religión budista es una religión de
estado normalmente la gente respecta a
los monjes pero lo que pasa es que estos
militares que tomaron el poder
están los responsables de este golpe de
estado no lo hacen tanto no hacen caso a
las presiones internacionales y los
cientos que iban a hacer caso de lo que
están diciendo desgraciadamente los
dientes budistas
ahora los militares han dirigido el
destino del país durante muchos años
pero ahora se enfrentan a esta juventud
que rechaza el futuro bajo el mando
militar podría los jóvenes doblegar a
estos militares si lee por favor
rápidamente que ya estamos acabando el
programa
bueno si esperas que
los jóvenes van a poder lo que es cierto
es que los militares no sospechaban este
rechazo masivo de la junta militar y los
jóvenes tienen esta ventaja de estar
conectados con el mundo entero pero
desde hecho desde hace poco los
militares trabajos de silenciar todos
los medios de comunicación es para que
lo que se llamará de la situación actual
sylvie gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en 5 minutos con de france 24
que tengo ustedes un muy buen día
ustedes también gracias por acompañarnos
hasta una próxima oportunidad
[Música]